the man accused of being a fake sign
language interpreter at the Nelson
Mandela memorial because he actually had
a bout of schizophrenia he told The
Associated Press he had visions of
angels coming into the stadium and has
been violent in the past and the man was
just standing three feet away from
President Obama and numerous on language
experts say all he was doing was signing
a gibberish at the end of the day a
South Africa's government says it's
investigating that's terrifying on so
many levels I mean the security issues
and not only that but how did Wiseman
have medication where where's the mental
health and the guns health in the
country that's really scary I get to
come to this where he's done this
several times this isn't the first time
he's done this but at this kind of
occasion yeah like when you have all of
the world leaders together this is the
guy that you want for that event but why
do I see Cecily strong on Saturday Night
Live oh my god no yes I mean it was made
for her yes I'm sorry it was made for
her she was drugged for Saturday Night
Live but it is sad I mean it is a mental
illness that people struggle with it if
you're untreated is very dangerous for
the people around you as well as the
individual